so thank you Julie once more and thank
you your team for organizing twice now
this agenda so if if you can join me
just in giving them again a round of
applause
so in fact I can attest that actually
Julie did read most of MIT what she said
but actually she did it before she
joined MIT
um and she came to me with those
questions during the interview process
so I was I was convinced that in about
18 months she and her team could pull
something like this together I didn't
know however that they would bring the
snow is winter on record to make sure
that there was proof that these efforts
were necessary I also want to take the
time to to thank you all of you for not
only joining us today and spending this
time but but really throughout this 18
months and what I hope to become many
many more years to come you will join
MIT in this effort because the challenge
that we're posing today and that you
will be talking about today is one that
I I've been very committed personally to
solving from many different angles um
and I'll I'll share some of my personal
experience today in the past few years
and then how that I believe needs to be
moving into the into the future
so this question
um that you've kind of put to us is one
that actually Julia and I spent a lot of
time talking about and I would say
that's probably the main reason she
joined MIT to become this changing force
in the campus sustainability Arena but
also as a show improve that this can be
done and that others can follow in the
in the spirit of MIT in just leading by
kind of walking this talk that we all
care about as you may have heard we are
in fact you can walk around the campus
and see we are under one of the
largest construction periods that MIT
has ever undertaken and I've I've shared
this with many of you that MIT has been
built in different bursts and there's
one when MIT came to Cambridge in 1916
there's another one in the 60s there's
another one in the early 2000s and now
what we ought to do is really renew the
campus infrastructure physical built
environment and Beyond
so it's an opportune time to really
think about what the campus should look
like in 2025 in 2030 not only from the
physical and design standpoint from the
operations from the research Mission but
also from the sustainability what do we
do what do we experiment with and what
do we prove to ourselves and to other
that can be done
so I have no doubt that this question
will be addressed in the best period of
MIT by bringing the best Minds to work
on these challenges and many of you
represent those Minds
so what I want to show you and and Julie
kind of has alluded to a couple of those
are the effect and the changes of
bringing folks to the table with
different perspectives
the first one is MIT Nana that by now I
think either everybody knows or
everybody suffers because if you are
located around building 12 you kind of
are suffering what's the highest
priority for MIT to have this Nanos
clean room nanoscale facility for
research Best in Class and what I can
attest again is that in the original
design I would say not much attention
was paid to sustainability which would
be common in a building that's driven by
the research and pushing the frontiers
of research and it took a while to
really bring those perspectives into
consideration to really make sure that
this was as committed to becoming the
best nanoscale research facility but
also to add and the greenness one
and I can also tell you that this one
had to come within a financial boundary
and this is another discussion we've had
and there's probably another Prejudice
out there that sustainability costs
money
and that is another question that
fundamentally I want to address and I
want to address in terms of life cycle
costs but I also want to address that
when you are early enough in the design
it doesn't cost that much to think about
options and those are the kinds of
challenges that I pushed to the design
team um through Julian through others to
make sure that this facility became the
example of what one can build in
nanoscale
the second one and this is just a
pictorical representation of what we're
envisioning to do in Kendall Square but
really it goes beyond this um Julie
talked about the ECOT District working
with our colleagues admit timko and the
City of Cambridge and and many of you
around this room we envisioned not only
to change the game in Kendall Square and
to accelerate the mission of MIT through
an enormous complex undertaking that's
what this will become it may take a
decade it may take a little less it may
take a little more but we also are
bringing into this discussion is how
we're actually envisioning this district
from the part of MIT and Beyond if one
goes north if one goes south The
Junction with the river the juncture
with our partners with our Innovation
partners with our mission partners
and thinking about in those domains and
rethinking the way sustainability plays
a role it will be very easy to think
about one of these buildings and say how
do we power how do we bring utilities to
one particular building
it's very different to think about the
system although MIT things about systems
all the time it's harder to think about
the system and it's harder to think
about the impact of how systems thinking
has something to do with it but again
through the force of just understanding
this process we wanted to make sure that
we were thinking about this new
generation of districts in a very
sustainable way
we're at the beginning of the design
phase and now the Architects and
engineers and teams are working really
hard to get this done
but when this is all done we want to be
proud not only of the Gateway entrance
to MIT once you come out of the T if the
t is running
but also at the same time be proud of
what this does in terms of energy and
climate so the other thing I wanted to
migrate to is
it's very easy I would say at MIT to
pull together for one day a group of
energetic individuals and get them
really energized and enthusiastic about
a topic it's actually that's the easy
part
the hardest part is to maintain that
enthusiasm moving forward and even the
hardest part is to actually affect
change at the MIT institution level
so we have a history and I've seen this
history now for a few years in which
maybe at a building there's somebody
who's particularly fond of an idea and
that gets done or a project or a system
and I'll submit that now all of you are
really committed partners in crime so
that we get sustainability the way we
should do it
but there's harder kind of a way to
elevate that discussion through the
governance process at MIT
and here there's a pioneering task force
the through the MIT energy initiative
there was a campus energy task force
so-called walk the talk and a group of
individuals a subset of of those I think
many of them I recognize them here this
is John Sturman from Sloan a great
Advocate down there for many many years
the slow new building being an example
of what MIT Nano would be in terms of
sustainability but it but if you wanted
to scale that and to use Julius terms if
you wanted to scale that how do you
scale that through the decision making
at MIT
so that task force was just that a bunch
of individuals that were committed to
doing it with no time in their hands to
get those things done so the first
decision was to create 18 months ago the
office of sustainability and to bring a
team of individuals who who sole
responsibility would be what Julie just
told you
the second part is to well now we not
only have the MIT energy initiative we
have the Environmental Solutions
initiatives
and we have I would say a senior
Administration perhaps starting by me
but certainly shared by many others are
committed to this issue to becoming a
game changer in how we think about the
campus sustainability of the future
so we've designed this now structure
that sits at the center the campus
sustainability task force I'll talk a
little bit about the membership but as
you see there are there are two main
institutional initiatives the
environmental one and the energy
initiative there's the office that Julie
leads with all her capable staff there's
the climate change conversation today
but the climate change conversation may
end and another one will come so you'll
see it around it but what's more
important to me is the bugs up above
this is not just a task force that's not
hooked into the decision making of MIT
in in a way that's fuzzy but it's
actually very clear and in this campus
sustainability steering committee you'll
see the membership in two slides we've
put the senior Administration and the
decision makers so that we all when we
make a decision we make sure that at
least the sustainability component will
be part of it
so we have had cost we have had research
purpose we have had time always in our
minds that's the typical thing of it I
want to make sure that sustainability
and and the cost to the environment is
also a dimension when we think about
decisions
so the co-chairs of the sustainability
task force our professor Andrea Andrea
Campbell and Julie and you see that the
membership we're aiming we're almost
done with securing the membership but
we're not there yet so I cannot announce
formally the full membership but they
will have membership from the five
schools from the two initiatives that I
talked about
from the climate conversation that's
going on today from Key administrative
areas most of you actually will be in
this and you know and from students from
the undergraduate undergraduate
community and this will create the
repository for all these conversations
and working groups and ideas that you
will generate today and into the next
few months and years
how those will be enacted how those will
be filtered how the will be prioritized
will come to the purpose of these task
force
so you see this is the steering
committee so we see this task force not
as a task force that generates ideas and
it's a collection of these days like
today but it is actually charting the
roadmap for MIT
how should MIT be the game change if we
don't have the best minds thinking and
Advising us
so that's what we hope for this task for
that Julie and Andrea as co-chairs
present to us with those best ideas for
the roadmap and we who in the end will
decide and and think about the
prioritization with all these
multi-variable problem
um we'll think about what the problem
and what the decision best fits with the
sustainability dimension in mind
so in closing um I just want to thank
again Julie and her team for this and I
want to thank all of you for what I know
that this will be a very energetic day
and a very enthusiastic day but also
don't fade make sure that this continues
because as Julie said this is not a day
this is not a month this is many years
into the making and I want to make sure
that we all have the energy to continue
thank you very much
thank you